hello everyone you've already seen my
previous upload it was the the mortal
polish game between Miguel and I drove
and the Ignacio glücksburg and a lot of
people are confusing these these two
games as this game is played between
Miguel Nitro and a person named leagues
bit and it was played approximately at
the same time although the year isn't
really known the mortal polish game some
say was played in 1927 some say was
played in 1929 and this game not
reverses leesburg is played in 1929 so a
lot of people are confusing these two
games but these are different games in
one game a turf is playing with the
black pieces in the other game another
is playing with the white pieces and
it's it's not the same person so another
saponin they are two different people
ok so so let's see this game another
physical and the glissberg is black we
have E 4 e 6 the French defense d4 d5
Knight to c3 now D captures on e4 Knight
captures any 40 and the Knight to d7
this is again Blackburn's move of the
Rubinstein variation of the French and
if you've seen my video where murasa
which makes that quick kill it seems
that well a lot of players so created
some very nice masterpieces against this
Rubinstein variation of the French so
neither of goes Knight to f3 we have a
nice G to f6 Bishop to d3 Bishop to e7
simply developing neither of castles and
we have b6 and here not of jumps in with
the knight Knight to e5 trying to take
advantage of this c6 square so we have a
bishop to b7 protecting and matter of
place knife captures on f6 and this is
kind of a critical moment of the game as
now well if black would capture with
Bishop Bishop captures on f6 he would be
ok but his opponent played actually G
captures on f6 and this allows neither
of to create a very complicated game for
black
he plays Knight captures on f7 and well
what are blacks options here well if he
moves the Queen he will lose the rook so
definitely the knight has to be captured
so vicksburg plays King captures on f7
and neither plays Queen to h5 would
check we have King to g8 and ok it's a
good move and rook to e1
threatening to capture this c6 pawn but
also having ideas of over roof lifts
which rook to e3 and rook to g3
so of course black defends this knife to
f8 not protecting that ECX pawn and here
well if you let the engine assess this
position the engine will say play Bishop
to h6 and this is and this is a small
advantage for white this will be
enjoyable for white but neither goes in
for the quick kill he plays the rook
captures on e6 sacrificing the rook and
well creating an extremely complicated
position for black we have Knight
captures on e6 and out Bishop to c4 now
pinning this night and well it's it's
definitely unpleasant to play this for
black he plays a queen to d6 and this is
an okay move black is holding this and
we have Bishop to h6 by night off and if
you look at this position now this is
well with correct play this would be an
equal position and black could play this
I mean black is two pieces up but if you
look at the position if this Queen ever
moves and lilies this Knight unprotected
and simply Bishop captures and he 6 will
be checkmate as the King has nowhere to
go and this is well the second critical
moment in the game what do you play here
for black I mean look at the position
and try to try to find a move for black
III for example have no idea what to
play here the engine says rook a to d8
but what does this move do why would you
play something like this and it seems
that it was hard for glissberg to to
come up with a move as well as he played
Bishop to f8 trying to exchange this
dark squared bishop and this is actually
the final blunder of the game as another
place rook to e1 and here we have a very
very dangerous threat here on on e6 so
this has to be defended
Bishop to c8 defending the knight and
now we have 28 and well there are all
sorts of threats here in the position
the simplest one rook captures an e6 and
this wins the game immediately so
glücksburg tries one more idea he plays
Bishop to d7 now attacking the Queen and
offers up his own rook so
he wants to give back some material you
know to try and get back into the game
but neither of isn't interested in this
matter of place rook captures on e6 he
sacrifices his Queen and well black
doesn't really have the luxury of of
declining this sacrifice if he would
play something like Bishop captures rook
on e6 then simply Queen captures on e6
with Czech Queen captures and a
beautiful double Bishop checkmate with
Bishop captures on e6 so after rook to
e6 the Queen does have to be accepted so
rook captures on e8 and here we have
rook captures 98 with a discovered check
from this bishop on c4 as the king he
has nowhere to go this check has to be
blocked we have Bishop today's Bishop to
e6 and now the very simple amorphous
opera game motive
we have Bishop captures any sex with
Czech deflecting the Queen Queen
captures on e6 and now rook captures on
f8 with checkmate so very similar to the
Murphy's opera game as a knight of his
only left with his rook that delivers
the checkmate and the dark squared
bishop which supports the rook so yeah
definitely a beautiful game and they saw
someone commenting on chess games
dot-org that night off really demolished
these globes Berg leagues better good
guys so yeah I do hope you enjoyed this
video as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I'll see you soon